foreign
and then you move into philosophical
Fellowship it's it's a thing I've
derived from Randall haves philosophical
contemplative
companionship or I forget what he calls
it he and I have emailed it's so what
I'm doing is not the same but it was
inspired by
so it goes something like this
you pick a philosophical text and you
prime people into this we're not going
to be reading this text in order to get
information from it we're going to be
reading this text in order to be
transformed by it we're going to use
this text as a way of trying to presence
a sage it's almost like a secular Seance
right you're gonna you're gonna presence
a stage
so that remember we talked about earlier
internalizing the sage that you really
can't do that unless you know the
presence of the perspectival knowing of
the sage is available to you so what
happens is first of all you read the
text very slowly
and then the speaker will pick out a
phrase that he or she thinks conveys
it and then everybody chants it like in
sequence and they chant it and they're
trying to convey as much and also
resonate with what they're sensing other
people are conveying so it's like jazz
and you do this and then you move into
simple speech everybody is allowed to
say no more than three sentences about
what is being provoked invoked and
evoked in their interaction with the
text and they have to try it and the
task is I want you to convey as much as
you possibly can in as few words as
possible
and so everybody does this but you can't
just do it atomically you have to pick
up on what other people have said when
you do your right simple speech and you
do that for several rounds and people
and what happens is people are also
asked try to sense how all of these
different perspectives converge back to
Spinoza or Plato or buber or whoever it
is and then you're doing that and then
you move into extended speech
everybody's now allowed to give three or
four sentences a bit more and open it up
and they can even relate it to some
experience that they've had in their
life
and you can see it's and then you move
into Free Speech where people just talk
about it and what happens is people get
a sense of
the text coming alive and Spinoza being
present or boob or being present
obviously not literally but in this
sense of there's something about the
intersection in the we space that gives
them a sense of what what was the mind
that generated or is the origin of all
of this and you're sort of and you
resonate with it and you pick it up and
it gives you an opportunity to
internalize the sage
I would love to try that have any of
those experiences been so memorable that
to this day you remember a specific
phrase from a text that
helped to catalyze
just an extraordinary
experience are there any that that
you've seen really light things on fire
in an interesting way
I think one in Spinoza was God is
related to the world the way the mind is
related to the body
oh can you say that one more time I'll
have to marinate with that one God is
related to the world in the same way the
mind is related to the body
I I forget where that's from I think it
might have been from the inundation of
the intellect I'm not sure